oh my god
do you hear me can you hear me newly
released 9-1-1 calls captured the
intense moments after two young girls
were shot when their fathers got into a
road rage argument
where's your emergency it happened on
Saturday October 8th in Nassau County
Florida officials there say 36-year-old
William Hale and 43 year old frank
Allison were driving in separate
vehicles along U.S Highway 1.
investigators say a cat and mouse game
of break checking soon began
multiple 9-1-1 calls came in for the
incident after both Franks and Allison's
daughters were shot during the argument
we're going down the road there could
have been two dead kids
because of Two Stupid grown men Nassau
County Sheriff Bill Leeper says Allison
attempted to run Hale's vehicle off the
road after that someone in Allison's
vehicle began flipping off hail someone
in Hale's vehicle then threw a plastic
water bottle into Allison's vehicle
moments later Hale's five-year-old
daughter was shot in the leg what a
scarier
and one crazy driver with a gun
two crazy drivers with a gun after
Allison allegedly shot Hale's daughter
hail fired back Sheriff Leeper says Hale
allegedly used everything in the clip of
his handgun Allison's 14 year old
daughter was shot and suffered a
collapsed
lungs
after both daughters were shot a string
of 9-1-1 calls came in reporting the
incident in one a child can be heard
saying she doesn't want to die
do you hear me can you hear me when
First Responders arrived to the scene
Allison and hail can be heard getting
into an argument in front of them
because of the graphic nature of the
video we have paused the body camera
image and are only playing the audio
[Laughter]
later in the body cam video one of the
daughters can be heard yelling out in
pain
we're on our way home these two are from
Georgia they're ugly
[Music]
both Allison and hail were later
arrested for their involvement in the
incident yeah the ride remains silent
anything you say can and will be used
against you in a court of law both
suspects now face attempted murder
charges for the incident for the latest
developments in this case an all things
True Crime stay with long crime Network
I'm Sierra Gillespie